foreign
ER okay he's bubbling up within me okay
right now you sure that that's an
explainer
well I go to the bathroom
what do you have for lunch
[Laughter]
so so I was just thinking
how much we take for granted about
when we use the word energy
and
it has profound Origins
I mean our understanding of energy has
profound Origins the Brilliance of Isaac
Newton who you know discovered the laws
of Optics and gravity and motion and
invented calculus
energy was not a fully developed Concept
in his time
and so so I just want to sort of spend a
few minutes offering
in appreciation
for a Triumph of the human intellect to
figure out what the hell energy is and
then how to manufacture it and exploit
it doesn't want to spend a few minutes
this is like a public service
announcement for energy out there yeah
one way to exploit it is got someone
sleepy Joe low energy very low energy so
uh energy is not a thing right you can
say a rock is a thing and you can point
to it or plan it as a thing and energy
is not a thing
so it was delayed in our ability to
understand what it was and how to think
about it
so we knew some things for example
when you had a Canon back when cannons
were like a popular tool in Warfare
right they were physicists at the time
who said hmm
I have a cannon ball and have this gun
powder and the cannon is made of iron
then I fire it and if I keep doing this
the cannon gets hotter and hotter
well where's that heat coming from
so what is it
and so in the urge to turn energy into a
thing early ideas was that there was
energy was a flu it was a thing that
could move in and out of objects
okay one of them they called it logistin
another one was a caloric
these were words invented to try to
think about
energy as an as a thing and then it
moves and it's got to be somewhere and
and so it kind of had more of this in it
than a cold Cannon and so and so those
are you had to start somewhere we were
crawling before we even could walk
and it wasn't until we understood
molecules and atoms and and that we were
able to say hmm
okay and and what role friction plays in
this we're able to say hmm
so you can store energy
in different ways
and when you store it it's not
manifesting itself
it's not saying here I am look it's not
really doing that and when you're
storing it no the object is not in
motion no the object is not you know
it's not all these things that it is
when it's manifesting
so let's take the simplest case a roller
coaster okay right every roller coaster
the first ascent
is the highest
yeah okay so what's going on so there
you go and you're leaning back and this
thing cranks you up
it is endowing you with energy
potential energy
stored energy
potential gravitational energy when you
get to the top
you can calculate how because we have
formulas for this calculate how much
gravitational energy it handed you so I
don't feel this energy yeah I don't know
what you're talking about until I push
you over that ledge right over the other
side of that Hill
then what happens is your potential
energy starts converting
to mechanical energy to kinetic energy
and it's an exact trade-off
an exact trade-offs so all that energy
they gave you at the top right okay now
is return with you speeding up as you
descend and that is when the ham
sandwich becomes actual vomit
a transformation of Another Kind right
um so and it's this trade-off and it
goes back and forth as you go up hills
and down if you go up a shorter Hill
then the first one okay you have enough
energy to reach the top of that Hill
because you started out with way more
energy than that at an even higher Hill
you're going to lose some energy to
friction
okay so in other words you can't Ascend
back to a hill exactly the same height
that you started in okay some energy
will go to friction and when you lose
energy to friction that makes heat
okay that's the source of heat when you
lose energy all right so that's why the
engine of your car gets hot right okay
not all the energy that you started with
got transferred to the motion of the car
the losses went to friction the friction
heated your engine your engine gets hot
okay so in a roller coaster you're
converting gravitational potential
energy to kinetic energy and back and
forth and back and forth and back and
forth and if they designed it right
the frictional energy that you lose okay
you don't go up higher and higher the
hills you go over have to get lower and
lower and there's the last one then you
come in for the stop right so they they
gave you the energy when you started at
the top of that hill so that's
gravitational potential energy becoming
kinetic energy that that's what's going
on there and like I said if you go back
up a shorter Hill you'll slow down
because some of the Connecticut is
giving back to you so you can have
another little lump of of potential
energy to take the next Hill that comes
after that
all right so that's easy we've had
roller coasters forever you could have
imagined them forever ago but it's more
complicated or a little more physics
involved if you want to say this
molecule has energy
a molecule
but how am I going to get the energy out
of the molecules just sitting there oh
well you can in one case burn it
burn the molecule okay why is it that
you can throw a log in the fire
and the log is room temperature you put
in the fire then the fire ignites the
log and the log keeps burning there's
there's chemical potential energy in the
molecules of the log
where did that energy come from what did
the log get that energy Chuck
you tell me right now
the log is it's it's from its molecules
it was storing where did its molecules
get their energy
oh okay let me think about this
um
oh from their atoms
[Laughter]
what did the log used to be no it used
to be a treat
uh tree how does the tree get energy
um from the Sun
thank you thank you
the sun builds molecules that contain
stored energy so that's why wood burns
because it has stored chemical energy
given to it by the sun look at that and
it's just sitting there minding its own
business but that's why fires and homes
are so deadly because this all this
potential energy stored in the molecules
of organic matter would if your house is
made of wood so that the whole thing
Burns
converting the chemical the chemical
energy into thermal energy
so so much of our Lives is the
conversion of energy of one form into
another
and what happens while that's going on
so other forms of energy there's energy
in the nucleus of an atom
yes you split the nucleus and taken it
we make bombs doing that
okay so we turn nuclear energy into the
kinetic energy of an explosion to do
damage to things in Warfare
okay that's nuclear or chemical energy
some chemicals will give you their
energy not slowly like a slowly burning
log they'll give it to you
catastrophically all right and we call
those bombs
okay or a firecracker catastrophically
boom the energy goes to break apart the
firecracker goes into the sound
that it makes the shock wave all of that
so our lives and everything we do
is nothing but a a ballet of the
conversion of energy from one form
into another do you know do you know
what the do you know what the french
word is for energy
I do not
calorie
okay
so so when we consume food that has
calories
a one for one definition of calorie is
energy but what does not have calories
of course are cigarettes which is
because they are not fattening and they
make you look so cool
foreign
think about it so you eat food that has
you look at the calorie content that's
how much energy it has okay so then you
consume it
you need energy to live to move your
heart beats all this requires energy
you're getting it from the calories of
the food you eat so what happens if you
consume more calories than you need
your body says
ignore that so it creates it creates
chemical potential energy in the form of
fat
and it stores it away I'm not fat I'm
just
filled with potential
you see this this is potential I am
potentially Michael B Jordan I am
potentially Michael B Jordan that's what
the potential
my six package is beneath the potential
all this potential
you don't even know what you can have
and by the way that conversion of your
body's calories to your energy is not
perfectly efficient
so what happens
to that excess energy that's not
converted it's that's the inefficiency
of your body all it we're an engine of
sorts it's inefficient so that
inefficiency gets converted to heat so
your body heats up when you exercise
right that's it's a consequence of the
inefficiency of your body but your body
loves that because now you you it's part
of your temperature regulating system
but I'm just saying you when you
exercise your body heats up in the same
way you drive a car the car heats up in
the same way the the wheels and the
tracks of a roller coaster are actually
getting hot because of the
inefficiencies of the conversion because
there's inefficiencies in every
conversion of energy from one form to
another so the only point of this
explainer is just to say so much of what
we do and how we live
involves the clever conversion of energy
from one form to another nuclear energy
chemical energy which is molecular uh we
have kinetic energy gravitational energy
all of this
comes together and our ability to
exploit that in the service of
civilization is one of the great
triumphs of physics especially 19th
century physics
where they figured out oh my gosh look
what we can do another quick one just
look at a locomotive right what's going
on there well the locomotive all right I
don't know if you remember they'd have
to fill up with from water tanks every
now and then okay well what does the
water do well a locomotive Burns either
coal or wood
and it heatsave so that's the chemical
energy it Heats a vat of water
so it's got the stored chemical energy
of the wood into the active thermal
energy of the vibrating water molecules
they then evaporate creating pressure
for the steam to then move Wheels
to have the locomotive go forward oh my
gosh
and that all started with solar energy
that made the wood or the coal that made
the the the the fire that made the
boiling water that made the pressure
that moved the wheels
all of this is a Triumph of our
understanding of energy now what you
just said there I can hear Exxon going
listen guys we're actually solar energy
okay
we got I just see It ultimately
ultimately guys this is solar energy
okay fossil fuels started as solar
energy this is true this is true it
reminds me and we got to end right now
it reminds me of this bumper sticker
it says no nukes right from the
anti-nuke movement and then the o
in the no is an image of the Sun
it says no nukes
I know what they mean they want you to
do solar energy but the sun Banks is
energy with nukes all right just like
make that clear here that's how that it
started that way
so anyhow I just thought I'd put all
that out there and so just to enhance
our appreciation for what energy does
for us and how being clever has enabled
us to build civilization on the
exploitation of converting energy from
one form into another
yeah it has built civilization and
ultimately it will
Destroyer on that happy note Chuck thank
you this has been another star talk
explainer this one on all forms of
energy and how it can create and destroy
all that we work for thank you Chuck for
that happy thoughts Neil deGrasse Tyson
here keep looking up
foreign
[Music]